storytelling is seductive from Awards in
the afterlife think suicide bombers to
conspiracy theories and this stems from
our universal weakness for narrative why
the stories bewitch us and could trading
the simplicity of a single story for a
messy incoherent reality equip us better
for life or our stories survival tools
and are they more vital now than ever
and we're going to start with Stanley
fish Stanley on my right is a literary
critic and a legal scholar he readily
contributes to new york times and is the
author of many wonderful books including
winning arguments Sophie finds is a film
director and producer her films include
the perverts guide to cinema featuring
Slavoj Zizek and the sequel the perverts
guide to ideology our next speaker is
Renata silletti Renata is a philosopher
sociologist and legal theorist she is
the author of perversion of love and
hate of on anxiety and her most recent
book is called the tyranny of choice
Stanley you have four minutes I always
begin my course on writing with a
question that I don't expect my students
to answer so that I can answer it myself
that's the whole that's the whole point
and that is what is a sentence anyway
what exactly does it do and as you might
imagine I give more than one answer to
this question but one of the answers I
give it early on is that a sentence
organizes items in the world now of
course that doesn't really tell you that
much about a sentence because file
cabinets and a great many other things
including your wallet or billfold if you
carry one also organize items in the
world so what is there that is special
or characteristic of the organization of
items performed by a sentence and the
answer to that at least the answer that
I give is that a sentence
places the items that has been that have
been picked out in a structure of
relationships in a structure of
relationships which are finite and can
in fact be enumerated and I'm giving you
here a short list the list is longer but
not that much longer relationships of
course in effect before and after that
is temporal relationships relationships
of contiguity and distance and in terms
of actions relationships that hang on
the mood or mode in which inaction is
performed there forward is called in
grammar the modal auxiliaries will could
can should may ought et cetera now all
of those and a couple of more are the
basic structural building blocks of
sentences but if a sentence is an
organization of items in the world in
relation to a finite set of logical
relationships a sentence is always in
the business of selecting because
organizing items in the world and
putting them into relationships means
that there are infinitely more
relationships you haven't put those
items into then ah then there are the
fairly singular single linear
relationship you have indeed created
when you create a sentence so that in
order to write sentences in order to
think of sentences in order to generate
sentences you must be actively engaged
in an act of exclusion that is the
excluding of all the other myriad
possibilities that might have been
actualized by other sentences of course
you can then write another sentence but
you'll meet the same problem all over
again
and then you can then write 3,000 other
sentences but you'll still be selecting
in ways that leave out more than is
concluded the English poet John Donne
complained about this and a poem called
anagram which is of course a poem about
the many ways that you can turn letters
into words and then take
the same words and turned them into
other words and he is his line his
complaint about linear language complain
about sentences quote in the lien dearth
of words what can you say in the lien
dirt wasn't that wonderful in the lien
dearth of words what can you say and his
answer is not very much or all you can
say is a single thing and that's why he
offers poetry as one among many other
possibilities of multiplying the
perspectives that might be framed within
a linguistic structure by all of the
tricks that poets use reversals making
you read backwards acrostics emblems and
printed in the poem etc so remember that
line from done so a sentence is a world
in which you at once create and step
into as a character because when you
create your sentence your thinking with
it and your thinking yourself into the
world that you were either that you are
at that moment both writing and living
now as I indicated a moment ago if you
are dissatisfied with your sentence oh
you want more then you step into another
sentence but as I have already said you
then encounter the same problem that is
you cannot step out of all sentences
into something immediate and totally
inclusive another way of saying that a
sentence is a world that you create and
a world that you inhabit is saying that
a world isn't a sentence is a narrative
a sentence is a small version of
narrative everything that's in a
sentence is in a larger narrative a
larger narrative is simply a larger
sentence and what that means is that
just as you can't step out of sentences
but only step from one sentence into
another equally but perhaps differently
limiting sentences sentence so you
cannot step out of narratives and so the
answer to the question is that
narratives
have Sutton so much power over us
because we live in them
cannot live outside them narratives are
us
thank you very much that's often a good
on a good note
Renate stories are really you know the
basis of our self perception and it is
when the stories that we are telling to
ourselves are collapsing that quite
often the most horrible things happen
and you know going to our title killer
stories we can say that in oven stories
with men scenarios when fantasies that
we have created about ourselves about
our place in the world and especially
about our place in the desire of the
others when they collapse that can you
know bring to the end the very subject
him or herself quite often we need
stories to answer the very painful
question often was I desired how was I
desired why did my parents have me you
know did they want me at all
French philosopher Louis Altis air in
his autobiography describes that his
whole life has been marked by death
because he got named Louis after you
know his mother actually lost before he
was born
the man he deeply loved so the man that
she was dating was named Louis after he
died she married another man and he she
gave her first son the name Louis and
loser deserves he said my whole life you
know was sort of like life where I lived
a person in a kind of the lost lover I
was sort of like a replacement for this
lost lover for my mother you know it is
maybe too much to speculate that that
maybe had certain kind of a link in an
unconscious way with the sad fact that
Luce Arthur sir
towards the end of his life actually
become a killer he killed his wife now
we might actually when the story about
ourself comes to an end or where we stop
believing it
we might actually kill not another but
ourselves psychoanalysts know that you
know when people sort of kind of stop
believing in a fantasy they have created
about themselves when they stop believin
in scenarios in stories about who they
are who they are for the others
some people might you know finish their
own life and Jacques Lacan for example
says that some people it is as if they
jump through the window of fantasy when
they lose you know that kind of a
narrative that holds that together
however also in the social setting you
know stories can have a killing effect
many wars started you know with the help
of stories some of you may be remembered
how the first gold war started with the
idea that there was a trauma that
happened in Kuwait that babies have been
killed in the incubator that was a story
which later was completely faked but you
know the war you know kind of needed
that story to get the approval Americans
needed that story to get the approval of
the Congress to go into the war in the
former Yugoslavia where I come from it
was also the case that you know the
conflict started with the help of the
story
[Applause]